hey everyone i'm pete soderling i'm the
founder of data council and the data
community fund
and
excited to bring you another episode of
dc thursdays where we chat with
leaders of top data companies and open
source projects
and today i'm very excited to have
graham thompson who's the founder and
ceo
of privacy dynamics graham welcome
thanks yeah happy to be here
um graham has a
checkered
background
[Music]
actually it's a fascinating background
and we're going to get into that a
little bit
but graham was previously at microsoft
and apple
he also has a mechanical engineering
degree from university of washington
and an mba from university of san
francisco
um graham you might not be the most
technical person we've had on the show
from a software engineering standpoint
but you sure hold your own
um in a deeply technical field when it
comes to starting startups so i want to
chat with you a little bit about that
and um and yeah we're really excited to
have you here
yeah absolutely thanks and
you know backgrounds are are interesting
uh so many things happen
throughout your career that kind of
guide you to what you end up doing but
um i've been fortunate to have a lot of
really cool jobs i look back on and have
such a big impact on on my ability to to
kind of execute now yeah awesome
um well tell us tell us about the early
start of your career and what that
looked like because i'm always
fascinated
at the variety of different stories we
get on the show
yeah well i mean it started mechanical
engineering started uh university of
washington
uh early on you know freshman year i was
didn't didn't know what i wanted to do
probably like most students
and knew i really enjoyed math and
sciences
but also kind of had this pull towards
like economics and business
really landed on engineering because it
was challenging and i found it fun and
hands-on and so i i resonated with the
ability to learn that path
but
you know as i got into the field of
mechanical engineering after college
i realized i was actually not very good
at it
i really liked the creative aspects of
it the the first you know 80 of the work
but the last 20 the detail you know
testing and and kind of operational
stuff i just wasn't very passionate
about
so i wasn't i probably wasn't a terribly
great employee uh early on doing kind of
the detail work that young engineers
often have to do
um and so you know i always had this
pole to kind of
use that as a foundation but but be more
on the
sort of building side and and
i really enjoyed the innovation work
which which naturally fit into
to startups and being a founder and and
now i get the option of coming up with
the
you know problem solved and come up with
the solutions but but then lean on our
on our engineering team to really
execute on that side of it so
awesome um and how did you get started
in data
so data really started back in like 2009
i was i was in business school at
university of san francisco and i was
riding bikes a lot with keenan rice from
looker at the time it was a turn and so
we were riding bikes like most mornings
before work
and this is like
ad tech was fairly new to me at that
point um and you could see it building
and the amount of data that companies
were collecting it was it was kind of
fascinating and as i moved you know out
of business school and and uh getting
into tech
uh data was always a space that that i
saw as as super important and
foundational to the future of tech
which obviously it has been now um and
that
those early days with keenan and getting
to know the business it sort of stuck
with me and so when eventually my wife
and i moved back to seattle i took a job
with microsoft that sort of
naturally worked at the same time that
they were starting looker so i had a
front row seat to
everything that was that was going on
with azure and in the early days of
azure at microsoft uh but also sort of
on the startup side with looker
and what was happening there so it was
just a
sort of benefit of being in the right
place uh with the right people around
that really got me excited about the
potential with data
awesome
um
and then from there
you uh you went to microsoft is that
right that that was sort of following
these conversations with kenan
yeah so uh in 2012 when we moved back uh
to migra to seattle and i took a job
with microsoft
you know
this was this the job market was so much
different than it is now and coming out
of business school in 2010 the job
market was bad
um and so i was literally looking for
anything at this point um being a
mechanical engineer with an mba
it's a unique background and with
engineering experience you know people
weren't hiring you for business roles
um and so i i found a role at microsoft
called it
was a technical evangelist and their
technical evangelists were across the
company
so there were really like maybe 10
titles at the company you know there's
like software engineer technical
evangelist business development manager
and technical evangelist is sort of in
between it's now often more referred to
as like developer developer relations or
developer advocate but back then it was
just all you know technical evangelists
and so um fortunately for me when i went
in
uh i joined a team that was led by
daniel lewin uh former like co-founder
of next with steve jobs and like someone
that out of the industry had the
entrepreneurial mindset but also
within microsoft you know his role was
was really to find interesting work for
the team to to go execute on and it was
such a wonderful position i ended up
working for him my whole career there
and he always did a wonderful job of
finding us interesting work and it went
from the early days of azure and the
developer relations stuff over into when
we started working more on trusted cloud
he started a an organization with under
brad smith uh for civic tech and the
idea was really around how do we
influence and and push forward
uh the policy and and uh some of the
work happening in government to make
sure that that they were innovating at
the same pace that the private sector
was and so i found myself in this really
interesting intersection of policy and
technology and and the growth of
sort of the migration to the to the
cloud
for a lot of big enterprise customers
and was that specifically
privacy related at the time your
interest in your work i wasn't told to
go work on privacy but at the time you
know when we're working with enterprise
customers remember they're all trying to
and these are big
slow-moving enterprises they were they
were trying to move to the cloud and
then microsoft was trying to sell them
on the benefits of ml and ai and some of
the compute related things that they
could do on azure once they got their
data there
but a lot of the friction around that
was
was starting to be developed with gdpr
and the privacy policy this is like 2014
2016
and so
what was happening is there was all
these concerns about okay yeah we're
going to invest millions of dollars
moving to azure we're going to start to
build out ml teams to take advantage of
that data once it's in the cloud
but what happens if tomorrow
you know new regulation essentially
disables our ability to to act on any of
it and so it was this big risk that they
weren't sure if they could make those
investments and actually capitalize on
them in the future and so our job was to
sort of
be do pre-sales and go in
uh and work with those customers to make
sure that their policies were uh secure
and the way that they were
actually setting up these workflows uh
would would last in a post gdpr world
and and that was the point where i
really started to hear repeatable
concerns from customers around like we
don't know what data is considered
sensitive like we don't know
when identifiable data is present and
this is
you know far beyond just the
identification of pii in a data set uh
but like
some of the breaches from netflix and
the the re-identification attack uh from
the netflix and imdb join
uh those were the things were actually
driving a lot of concern and people were
saying well we're not going to do
anything we're actually not going to use
that data because there's too much risk
uh from a
brand and and trust perspective from our
customers and
that we just heard that over and over
and over again
and so um
and and
how did this relate to this job of um
you you you talk about it as well you
didn't call it devrel but um the sort of
technical advocacy like how how did
these two things
collide in terms of what your what your
personal responsibilities were at the
company at the time yeah so the the
beauty of the position that i was in
as a
you know technical evangelist or doing
pre-sales is i didn't have a quota and
so i could go find interesting things
that i thought might pan out three five
seven years from now
uh or from then
and
and dig in on them and daniel is so good
about giving us the freedom to to do
that and really look at are you moving
the needle over the course of several
years
um it sort of gave me the freedom and
the platform to to go design
exactly the startup that we'd want to go
build um so i i look at it as a very
fortunate position that i was in to to
be able to do that and all i had to do
was sort of pay attention um
yeah and so um and then so what what's
the sort of founding story behind
privacy dynamics how did you you know
move from
some of these insights that you were
getting and the setup and the
overall data ecosystem privacy world
that led to the founding of the company
tell me about how you connect those dots
yeah i mean i look at it as a whole
bunch of puzzle pieces that are sort of
out on the table and as you start to fit
them together it becomes more clear on
your vision
so there was a bunch of things that that
were going on at the time
in civic tech there there was
sort of the friction for collaborating
between public and private sector so i
think a good example is
as uber was really taking off and
starting to integrate with cities uber
is a really good last mile service but
cities were having a
tough time connecting
that last mile with like their their
infrastructure for transit so you there
was no way
at the time to say okay
can i take an uber to the train station
and then the train station downtown and
that's the best path for for my commute
uh because there was no data sharing
happening and and the reason for that
was often that uh the private sector
companies didn't trust handing data over
to the public sector they didn't they
wouldn't hand data over to the city to
integrate that and at the same time the
city
uh had a lot of political risk from
anything being disclosed for data that
they had so if they disclose information
that's that's like political suicide for
them um and so
there was just a stalemate and so
initially uh the thought was okay how do
for from a public good standpoint data
sharing is everything and the concerns
around disclosure for individuals is
really what's causing that friction so
how do we solve that problem and the
first thing that we thought of was
sort of a research data collaborative
that happens a lot in in healthcare uh
so a university research you know uh
organization will will be the host of
data from a bunch of partners
and so i i had it in my mind that we
would be this like third party data
collaborative and and privacy dynamics
would be the intermediary that would
host the data anonymize it and then make
it available for for research or
collaboration and i literally was like
pitching uh lyft and the city of seattle
and and uber and the state of washington
like trying to do these big
uh
collaborations
and when i was at microsoft those
conversations were easy right it was
like oh yeah microsoft you got to do
that and we actually built one
uh for the the
supreme court in the state of washington
it's that's still running now
but the second i left microsoft i'd make
those phone calls like i called lyft i
was like hey you know we're gonna go
start this this uh third bar third-party
data collaborative for for mobility and
it's going to be great
like
nobody it went nowhere
it was like yeah right we're going to
send all of our data to a startup a good
idea
um and so we had to we're going to let
you and we're going to let you
de-anonymize it right exactly so um that
was a pretty good lesson that
that you just have to be willing to to
admit that you're wrong like okay that
was the wrong path like what's next how
do we adjust and like what do we do
after that
and
this happens in multiple areas you know
and you hear it from vcs you hear it
from customers you hear it from you know
employees uh and engineers that say
that's technically not possible or or we
can't build it that way um and as the
founder and as the leader of that it's
your job to
filter that correctly right like
some of it's really really good and you
need to listen to it others
it's sort of a not right now or or
doesn't quite fit into the puzzle we
can't use that piece yet
um but that's probably the hardest thing
about uh being a founder is just knowing
when to plug in the piece and when when
not to and you're not always right when
you do it
so was this your first wf io moment
uh one of them yeah
i think it's your your one of your more
favorite acronyms from ben horowitz so
tell us tell us about what that means
so it's uh we're aft it's over um just
moments that you think like what am i
doing
it was it was a fun idea and even
um
you know early on when i started this
there are certain people along the way
that said oh why don't you go do it my
wife being one of them it's like why
don't you go do that sure and
unfortunately like she's the smart one
of the group
uh and with the stable job
and so she was like yeah you should go
do that why not and those little those
people you know her and several others
when they say that it gives you the
encouragement to to try
um and so when you have these moments of
like oh it's over for me it was like
i'll just go back to working in big tech
i'll just you know go find a job again i
guess
um and that happened several times like
i remember looking at google's job board
at one point being like
i guess i could do some of these
but the biggest one was probably when we
realized that data collaborative was not
going to work
and i actually called uh one of the
privacy researchers that used to work
with the microsoft who's at google and
we sat down and had coffee and she said
something in that conversation that and
she was like
what we haven't done yet that the
industry is waiting for is the ability
to measure privacy
like that hit me
that conversation
i i left and i was like that's that's it
we have to dig in on on doing a better
job measuring probably quantifying
privacy risk
as a
sort of foundational piece for how we
move forward as an industry not not just
privacy dynamics but like until we can
better understand how to how to measure
privacy
we can't execute on
these vague regulations and policies
that are being set
and so
so that was an inspiring conversation um
and how did that sort of change your
thinking about the problem space and or
or the solution that you were going to
offer well it became uh so then the next
phase of the pitches and
mind you i was pitching
any investor i could i could talk to
this entire time like
trying to that's why
speak yeah
i would love to go back and look at the
first pitch that i gave you and see
where we were i think it was here on
like the measurement stuff
um
and
and so i was very convinced like if we
can quantify privacy risk everything
else falls in line
and if you can start to layer that and
this is where the looker stuff starts
coming back and like if you can start to
layer that on the data stack that's
that's evolving now on top of snowflake
now it becomes a tool now it becomes a
tool that that's the basis for all the
privacy transformation that you do going
forward
um because one of the core thesis and
the vision that that i had that's still
true today and it was true at the very
beginning was that the cost of privacy
is too high and and that's sort of what
it boiled down to
the cost being engineering time the cost
being like not using data and ways that
are valuable to the company
um and then the actual cost of the
you know compliance
and so
to me if if we can do better tools and
reduce that cost of privacy mainly
around the value of the data coming the
value of anonymized data
that's
that was the like core fundamental
thesis of of the company and so to me
the ip was how do we measure and
quantify privacy risk
um the challenge with that is it's
category creation like you're going to
to vcs that are looking at a market this
is before privacy was and dev tools were
really you know hot at all in data
infrastructure
and it was like yeah it seems
interesting but how many people care
about that
um and and keep in mind i was still in
the under the impression that most
companies wanted to be privacy perfect
right they wanted to have this like
stand-up best-in-class privacy practice
to build on trust because that's what
that's what worked for microsoft and
azure was this sort of trusted
initiative
um
and we can get into you know when i
finally decided that that privacy
perfection was not not the goal
well this whole um i love this
conversation because it sort of reflects
the
um
the process um some of its intuition
some of it's
running a process some of it's like
committing to the process and giving
yourself up to the process as a founder
and it's essentially this process of
just constant
iteration and i imagine that
you were probably talking to
three groups of people through all of
these iterations um
one is the investors that you're
probably continuing to keep open threads
with one is his customers and trying to
sort of you know socialize this amongst
the market amongst early users and then
the third is your team and
um all three of those
groups can
be challenging to to manage during you
know such as a an interview process i'm
just curious as to
how you did that and how you structured
that did you
um did you sort of have the awareness of
what was going on
as you were you know in in the forest or
you know was it really just like you're
just trying to avoid trees
yeah i mean
a lot of it's just not a necessity of
don't die
like stay alive uh i i made a deal uh
with my wife early that i would always
keep getting paid and so and investors
and it was a like a
fraction of the salary that i was used
to but it was like just the bare minimum
and that was the goal if there ever came
a time where i couldn't make a paycheck
i had to start looking for a job and she
like held me to that which actually
was was really important for
the what it drove me to do and how it
drove me to think
um
and so it just accountability is super
important as a founder so wherever you
get it you have to get it
but
on
there was actually a fourth group too
that that was pretty important as a
as an influencer to me and that fourth
group was
academic research so privacy research
there's this whole group of privacy
researchers that have a ton of respect
for that have really pushed the industry
forward uh people like uh ryan kayla at
uw and woody hartzog and uh dana boyd
and people that are that have really
contributed a lot to the awareness and
understanding of data privacy
and so that was trying to respect their
their views and their opinions and all
that that they know about it but
building something that was useful for
the enterprise so they would actually
deploy it so that you know the cost of
privacy perfection is really really high
um but at what level will an enterprise
deploy this at scale so that we can
actually start to
make progress towards you know uh more
ethical and and privacy safe data
science and ai and ml et cetera
um
and so balancing all of those was hard
and there were key moments along the way
that
going back and forth between all four of
those groups was critical and getting
uh
insight and feedback that you can trust
from all four of those groups was was
critical to seeing how that puzzle
starts to come together right and seeing
which pieces fit and
get at least getting the boundaries set
and one of
there's a bunch of key moments there
you know
two that that really come to mind one
from a cto at a company the consumer
company
uh that collects a lot of really
sensitive personal like location
information
um and i i thought oh this is a perfect
early adopter for us a design partner
um like they need us just as much as we
need them
and he said to me he said
look privacy is important to us but we
really don't care about privacy we care
about the data like as a business the
business is on the data and so we we're
not going to build a privacy business
like the business is the data we need to
check the box on privacy and hit the
switch but we don't necessarily care if
you tell us that it's good enough like
we believe you
um and that was hard for me to hear
because i've been building this whole
thing on the notion that people wanted
to be more privacy perfect
um
and
so that that took me a few days to
really digest but it was
a super critical point in the in the
journey of of what we do in sort of
setting this
switch of saying you trust us to run the
transformation you tell us what you need
out of the data and like we'll run the
transformation to make sure that
it meets the privacy requirements that
you're setting
but then we'll we'll deliver data that
meets the sort of analytics standards
and and requirements that you have
um and and that that moment was a scary
shift and that was the shift kind of
right when
uh you really got involved and
and a few of our you know kent goldman
our pre-seat investor we had three
months of runway left from him and i i
told him we were making this big shift
to like the data engineering side and
started doing no code for
uh on the on the privacy side
and
he was like are you sure
and uh
uh
bless him he he's been a really good
investor for us that he
again holds me accountable and like is
honest but at the same time uh when i
when i shared that conviction of that
was the path uh he he said okay like go
for it
that's great yeah um and so then
you're you're balancing um the the
customer feedback you're getting you're
sort of iterating
on ideas
um what what was the nature of the
product that finally came out of this
process so so basically
tell us about the privacy dynamic
product now um and and who it's for and
what it looks like
yeah so and this was uh came out of
another one of those discussions from
those four stakeholders was um
so i had attended through the uh the
looker team keenan and ben porterfield
were early investors and so i stayed
pretty close to them
um and and went to the 5 train user
conference with them and met taylor
brown this was pretty early 5 train
and i was talking to taylor and he's
like oh yeah all of our customers
struggle with this
and so i that was my first sort of
introduction into five tran
and then you know fast forward 18 months
or two years even after that
conversation
at 18 months um
they did a fireside chat with scott
brighton other from from brooklyn data
company so i think it was scott and and
taylor and uh
tristan handy from dpt
and this came this conversation around
privacy sort of came up and one of them
and so i thought wow i should really
reach out to this crew because like
they're seeing all the same issues that
that
we believe
and so i literally cold emailed scott
afterwards and just said hey i really
enjoyed the talk like i would love to
share what we do
and he responded right away
and it was a a great lesson for me that
people in this in this space and in the
data infrastructure space especially
they care so much about moving the
industry forward and they're just great
people like they want to help they they
want to get involved and so
that kicked off a really good
partnership uh with them
uh and they've just been a wonderful
design partner all
through the entire process
but but that led us down this path of
like really getting to know data
engineers
and what they care about and so now the
product is is tries to stay out of the
way as much as possible
fits in uh really seamlessly on top of
like the snowflake dbt uh workflow where
uh you sort of transforming data and
getting it into a stable state uh in a
schema and snowflake and then if you
want to clean it you literally just turn
on our switch and you say here are the
parameters of what i'm looking for in
the data um run it and and create this
uh this clean uh table and and dump it
into a schema that i can use
and taking out all of the
manual process that that historically
has been the way that the privacy
transformations are done to understand
you know how do i need to treat each
record in this data set to to make sure
that it's not identifiable um
and what adjustments do i need to make
like we we can take care of all that on
our end
so that that's really where the product
ended up got it
um and would you say that the current
product is
um
more in line with the lowering the cost
of of privacy or it's more in the line
of
measuring the the measurement aspect of
the privacy or or both like how are
those two things sort of
um you know being traded off or or are
they being traded off in your existing
product
yeah they're they're totally dependent
on one another and so
in order to lower the cost of privacy
you have to be more
precise with with what you're doing to
your data so
um in the case where
there's a common approach is like column
wise treatment to data so if you have uh
there's direct identifiers like name and
phone number and social security number
that use
they're direct identifiers that you need
to redact or mask or
you know tokenize
but then on the indirect identifiers
these are the ones that are a little bit
harder to understand and see
but that they're the ones that you can
attribute back and re-identify an
individual so sort of the breach risk
um
these are the things where you could
just to be clear where you could sort of
mash together a couple data sets and
and de-anonymize it through some of
these indirect
um you know qualifiers that might not be
necessarily obvious as as pii
exactly the easiest one um
to articulate to the audience is just if
you have uh age gender and zip code for
instance
if if the age
for example is very high like say the
age is 110 years old and the zip code is
this jackson hole uh in a small area of
jacksonville
most people are going to know who that
person is right there's only 110 year
old person in that area and so if you
have any sort of background knowledge
of of that domain
or that that data set you're gonna be
able to identify that person if that has
health data associated with it like uh
you know
cancer data you would then be able to
attribute that that person has cancer
and that's a violation of hipaa so
um
those are the things that are that are a
little bit harder to find in these huge
data sets that we're creating now
especially in health tech and
all of us have these unique digital
fingerprints um
and and so
for for us layering on top of where that
data is sitting in the data warehouse
and before it's being used uh downstream
just being able to have that checked and
say hey is anything in this data set
standing out that that could be at risk
uh for that individual and do we need to
do a minor tweak do we need to adjust
that age from 110 down to 103
because there's now we have 203 year
olds
and and just that
just that grouping or that coupling uh
allows you to to
you know uh determine that the data
set's been de-identified so that's it's
that's largely based on k anonymity uh
which hipaa and
for those that don't know hipaa hipaa
can go through either safe harbor where
you like strip out certain types of data
or
expert determination where you've kind
of determined that there's a very small
risk of data being identified
and and to do that
uh
it was largely based on k anonymity and
now there's some variations of that
happening now they're a little bit more
uh accurate but
we've kind of coupled together a few of
these techniques to ensure that the
data no single record is standing alone
and it always sort of has a partner to
to offer that anonymity
and so
and so the focus of the current project
project the current tool set is to
enable
data engineers to sort of operate in a
privacy safe
way
with as little friction
as possible and i mean just hearing you
talk about it i think you you have the
capacity to make something that
generally sounds painful and tedious and
and unsexy um for for engineers um you
know sexy again or you know at least at
least palatable
um
that that's it seems like as i've seen
you develop the the product vision over
time
like that's been something that you've
been able to do um do you have any any
comments on that in regards to how
engineers are
approaching your tooling now and and
what the responses are
yeah i mean i i don't think we'll ever
be successful making privacy sexy
it's uh
and that's that's okay
i think efficiency is sexy and
like if you can take operational past
stuff off an engineer's plate like data
engineers are being asked to do so much
now at organizations
um and and now the sort of
evolution of the analytics engineer role
and they're being asked to a lot of
organizations
but ultimately they all have to work
together on
raw data is landing in a data warehouse
we have to sort of clean that up and get
it ready uh to provide
you know
good quality data downstream to whether
it's a bi team or a ml you know
engineering team or uh publishing the
data to partners
you have to do a lot of work to prepare
that data and one of those steps is
often anonymizing it or ensuring that
you're not going to disclose something
sensitive
and so that step
if you ask a data engineer to
verify or treat a data set to be
anonymized like they're very rarely do
they have any privacy
experience or or training
and so we said okay how do we
support the work that they have to do
and and designing and developing that
data product the way that they want it
and we take care of the privacy side we
say okay we understand how you want the
data to look
now let us
run those minor adjustments that we need
to to to
eliminate that risk that that someone
could be singled out
and so by balancing that and our
engineering team just did a phenomenal
job kind of taking the
note i i don't even want to say no code
right now because so many engineers give
me a hard time for it but it really is
like looking at the privacy
transformation side it's no code for
privacy transformation but on the like
analytics configuration side like you
get all the controls for that
and so uh
to to me and what the data engineers
have been so positively responsive over
is
okay you made our job a lot easier to go
through this step that again we don't
care about we we know we need to check
the box on it and and ethically it's
important to us but we don't care about
going into the nitty-gritty on how to
treat each record we actually care more
about getting this data set published so
we can go on to the next task in the
next you know
job that we have to do
yeah well we've talked about this before
i mean i personally love the strategy
because
um
you figure out a way inside the existing
tool chain
to integrate privacy a privacy tool
um in in an effective way
um and as long as you
maintain that spot in the workflow and
engineers sort of agree with you by
using your product
then you privacy dynamics get to sort of
change or update or
[Music]
innovate on the algos behind that spot
in the tool chain in the tool chain
and and sort of use best of breed
research or change your anonymization
techniques or
build that out to be a very robust thing
over time and that's that's sort of
um regardless of you know well it it's
because of your place in the tooling um
uh to in the tool chain but that's sort
of all like abstracted away for the
engineers who are just basically
committing to use your tool because
um you know you're the best thing that
they can find when it comes to
um fulfilling privacy obligations in
their in their data engineering
workflows
yeah and we really wanted to focus on
that top to bottom in the business of
the way it's designed and built but also
the way it's it's turned on
um and so fortunately that the
enterprise security and privacy tooling
stack is moving more towards bottom up
like product led growth type strategies
uh and in the way that software is being
procured at organizations is changing
which is really helpful to us
because
one of the
the big trends that's shifting now
especially in privacy and compliance is
we've had the maturity of of the
compliance tool uh platforms right so
first it was one trust now big id and
these these big companies that have
expansive platforms to manage all of
your privacy across the stack
and those are really good for big
enterprise but they're often way too
much for small and mid-sized businesses
that have you know teams of five and ten
engineers
um and so that really just aren't
concerned about doing all those tasks
yet
um and so for us going in and saying
here's a tool you can turn on and start
using in five minutes like you can
literally go on our on our site and like
turn it on and start using it within
minutes and can just connect it to your
warehouse
and that was important for us because if
if uh
the the persona that we designed that
around was a data engineer is asked to
anonymize a data set
they they literally go search like how
to anonymize the data set and then
they're running manual they're writing
like you know their own sql and trying
to figure out you know how to do that
where instead if they can just point it
to our our tool and and get a get a
clean data set in return it's going to
be a lot more reliable a lot more
consistent
and actually meet the requirements that
the
compliance or privacy teams or even
regulators would want to see
and improve that workflow for them and
now
instead of a compliance team at a
certain size company instead of a
compliance team pushing down a platform
on an engineer and saying you have to
pull data through this process and being
restrictive now the engineers can go up
and say oh no i followed that policy
by using this tool like
you know aren't you proud of me
and what we found from compliance
leaders and privacy leaders is they were
so relieved that they didn't have to go
push tools down to engineering anymore
and that
actually engineers have the tooling to
to sort of follow protocols
and and work up the chain so that's been
a really a really big relief for us
uh to see that as we can grow our
footprint within an organization and
have more engineers using the tool we
actually get support from the from the
compliance and private
teams
yeah that's great
um so then what what's the process for
creating
a policy in privacy dynamics like who do
you see
it must be collaboration amongst
different stakeholders in different
teams to basically configure the tool
um to sort of generate the level of
privacy that's expected of that
particular
organization what does that process
typically look like
yeah so this is where
contextually every dataset's different
every use case is different and to
design around that was really hard right
like we we can't
uh automate and and guess what if you're
releasing a data set like i don't know
who you're releasing it to i don't know
what's in the data
and so to provide a tool that supports
that was was a big challenge and what we
landed on um
and what our engineering and our data
science team did together that was so
special was
uh essentially creating a dial
and
if you look at that k anonymity is the
simplest metric to talk about it's like
k2 is a group of two or more and k k5 is
a group of five or more so you're just
adjusting the group size and then the
likelihood that someone could be
re-identified
and its simplest terms would be like one
out of two one out of five one out of
ten
and then you can do sampling and and uh
kind of
provide an estimate that way but for a
user
they can quickly understand like k2 is a
little
less protected than k10 but the
granularity of the data is going to be
higher it's like okay i can just play
with this dial and i can see
so quickly on the report you'll see like
what what changes in the data and how
the shape of the data and the analytics
and the data change whether it's you
care about
correlation between two fields or or
sort of the mean median
uh stat uh stats but
as you're adjusting that dial and you're
treating the data more or less
you can say okay here's what we need out
of the data here's how accurate we need
the data to be for our ml training maybe
um
and now i know what the privacy
or threshold is that this data meets and
now downstream i can say okay this data
is not suitable for publishing online
and we need some policies and parameters
around that
for how to use it and what not to do
with it
but at least that transparency is there
about how the data is risky if at all
so that was one big step and then on the
if policy is being pushed down for data
publishing for instance a company might
have a policy to say uh hipaa is a good
example like k2
is suitable for for hipaa and uh
healthcare research so
if if you need to publish it k2 you said
k2 in our tool ensures that the data set
comes out at k2 and no more
there's actually a big
uh utility loss if you start going above
that if you over anonymize data that's
when it gets really bad and the
perception of anonymized data gets
really poor
as if you're just over anonymizing it it
becomes
sort of useless and very
vanilla or you know lacks insights
when you mention sort of the statistical
um
you know notion of of um or the process
of of cleaning up or or tokenizing or
anonymizing some of this data
um it strikes me that that's
sort of adjacent to like a data quality
discussion um do you use anything like
great expectations behind the scenes to
help
sort of um you know deliver this
make this process work yeah so great
expectations is pretty close uh through
the root portfolio i think yours um
and so
uh
that that's been a discussion i think as
you know we just launched the public
data of it today
um
and you know that's been a discussion
because if we can integrate and support
tools like great expectations
you you could see a
scenario where you have a
data pipeline running uh and we we
orchestrate in the same that same flow
you could
set something like you know
maintain a
privacy threshold of x and if it falls
below that run privacy dynamics again to
treat it
and so there's a lot of
uh
sort of alignment between all of these
tools and as teams build their stacks
um
you know that that's one thing that we
want to encourage and why i think the
data infrastructure uh group is so so
good at collaborating together is
because they see the benefits for for
customers of coupling these tools
together you know dbt has been a great
connector for all of these groups too
[Music]
yeah very cool
um
well it's neat when you start to um
sort of uh what's what's the right word
i don't know if atomize is the right
word but when you start to sort of um
create clear
separations of concerns and you come up
with the right abstractions
in the way you think about
data engineering tooling and sort of
what needs to be built where
i think these adjacencies and
um
you know the the beauty of the way the
whole ecosystem fits together
um starts to become more clear but it's
literally from
founders you know like you or like abe
or whoever who are
um
you know insisting on
trying to be as tight and they're
thinking about the proper types and
nature of the abstractions as possible
and it's really amazing once you start
to see a whole team or a whole community
of folks um you know work on those
challenges um in in a clear-headed way
yeah and i think it's important to stay
focused on like i know our value out is
in transformation like just if we can
run the privacy transformations now
and i'm not trying to
add product to grow revenue across all
these different areas where i i suddenly
feel like everyone's a competitor
if we just stay focused on contributing
the core value of our products and and
sort of relying on everyone else to to
you know do the same in their lanes
now you can start to see really good
experiences form for the industry
um and so if i can collaborate with with
partners that do like big id for
instance is a perfect example they do a
really good job with all the uh privacy
and compliance tasks that are downstream
from us yeah
and investors asked really early like oh
when are you going to get into the into
compliance there's more money in
compliance it's like i why why would we
get into compliance there's already
companies doing a really good job with
that so if we can feed
information about
privacy risks and data sets to a big id
now they can do a better job uh sort of
doing the data mapping and doing all
those tasks that they do so well with
and now we're just feeding their
ecosystem
if we can build our business model
around that and ours is all around it's
just like five trans around consumption
it makes all of that possible and all
those channels become more valuable
um and and so i
i'm a big fan of
partnering versus trying to eat away at
revenue in other areas
yeah great well i'm really excited to
hear about your public beta um
tell us about the the kinds of use cases
that you know your design partners or
your early customers that you've been
working you know with the with the
closer um group like how has that been
going and what are folks using the tool
for
yeah so there's sort of three main use
cases that we're seeing bubble up the
most and i i'm learning new ones all the
time too so um you know please don't
feel like i'm i'm omitting you if you
hear this and and you have a use case
i'd love to hear it but there's sort of
three main
themes that it falls around
the first and the most obvious is data
publishing so anytime data is being
published out of the company you want to
ensure that you can't control what's
being what it's being joined with later
you'd want to make sure that it's pretty
locked down in terms of the likelihood
that you could have this sort of
re-linking attack that that
got netflix and imdb um and so i don't
know if people are familiar with the
netflix breach it was they they had a
contest that they released a data set of
movie watching and someone joined it
with an imdb data set and was able to
map back the profile from imdb to to the
netflix account
and so those publishing risks you can't
control external knowledge like what
information background knowledge that
someone has
on the
data subjects and so
you really want to probably anonymize
that more
so that's use case one this happens a
lot in healthcare
like pharmaceutical research
those data sets are published under
hipaa and expert determination so um we
we do some of some of that and then
really in the growth of health tech and
all these health tech companies
using phi
uh and health information and data sets
for
uh really interesting personalized
services and and uh innovative things uh
on the health tech side
the data teams that are using that that
information
uh have concerns around is this data you
know safe under hipaa uh policies and
procedures and so running it through our
like as they're pulling it out of their
data warehouse and running it through
our tool for uh training and early dev
and tests uh it's a really good way to
to do that and even in production if
you're running a production model off of
it
that's when we get into these like great
expectations conversations uh about
setting up a pipeline that maintains
that
that threshold so that's one that's
that's a pretty exciting one uh two is
just internal analytics and bi and so if
you have all of your customer data and
you're trying to figure out things like
churn or what's causing customers to
increase consumption of your product
you don't necessarily want to provide
all that detailed customer information
to every team across the company that
that would be
garnering these insights and so giving
them access to schemas that have been
cleaned or
have these sort of micro transformations
to make sure it's privacy safe
now you can really reduce the exposure
that you have from a security
perspective on who has access to that
customer data
and that can continue to power really
strong analytics and bi
and then the third um the third one is
that that's growing and
actually um lee marie braswell wrote
about this not too long ago uh in their
founders fund uh post and and really
articulate it nicely uh if you wanna
read more about it on our blog
but the ml training data
so ml training data
there's a few different options for it
now like a lot of people are using
synthetic data and building sort of
models
and training neural nets to do that
another option is just
this transformation of raw data and
making sure that you you dump that into
a schema that that can power the the ml
training
so it's a little bit
more of a kind of hybrid synthetic
approach where some of the data has been
adjusted or you could consider it
synthetic
but but a large percentage of the data
still remains the original uh set and so
you can
maintain a lot of the messiness of
original data
because often those those train models
are very smooth they're very like
sort of they don't represent real world
data very well um and and so sometimes
you want that in your models
got it
um and from a product roadmaps map
standpoint like what are you most
excited about
in terms of the the privacy dynamics
roadmap
yeah so one of the what we what we
launched today is is the sas public data
and so you can go on the site and start
playing around with it there's sample
data
you can connect to a snowflake data
warehouse and and start to play with
data that you have
um
but we know that
at a certain point an organization and
even smaller teams
don't necessarily want to send sensitive
data to a service and get it back
and so on the roadmap that that we have
privately available now and it'll be
publicly uh available soon uh is
deployment through replicated and in a
kubernetes instance so you can start to
run it in your local aws environment or
azure environment and
run it as a dedicated service on-prem so
now data doesn't have to come to us and
go back so this is where a lot of the
healthcare
companies uh are ending up as
running that on-prem so
you just get into a lot simpler uh
policies and procedures and agreements
if that data doesn't actually leave
their domain
um we have a question coming in from
youtube
um someone is asking about
attribute access
applying
for that policy i assume that means um
sort of how does a policy get triggered
in the system
like uh maybe
like attribute based access controls and
stuff
yeah perhaps um
let's see if we can get any additional
clarification
i'm happy to to follow up on it but what
i would assume that question is around
is can you set uh access controls based
on like privacy scores for instance
um or like privacy um
uh numbers and so one of the areas that
i'm excited about and one of the
products actually the dbt launch is is
our metadata product
uh that allows
uh you know write back information into
into the metadata and the dbt project
and so one of those areas that
that we're looking at is like the
privacy uh
score for that data set so pre-treatment
post-treatment either one but maybe both
and now you can start to set access
controls based on uh that data so that
that would be an area that we can
explore but uh we look at this a lot as
our our job
as you get really narrow is to sort of
measure and treat the data and allow you
to set a
set a target and meet that target for
privacy risk and then make that data
available to users to set whatever
controls for access that they want
downstream
so we'll be very open with making that
data available we are very open about
making that data available for those
reasons
got it got it
well graham um this has been a great
chat it's it's always i'm great to talk
to you and and super glad that you made
the time for us i just wanted to ask you
a parting question before we let you go
yeah what what surprised you most
about your work in the data ecosystem so
far
um
i
honestly it's it's the people and how
amazing the people have been i i
mentioned it earlier too but
everyone is so passionate about
you know improving the the
products and and you know basically
enabling companies to to do their best
work by giving them better
a better data stack
and
there's i've always had this theory that
engineers are
committed to making the world a better
place like that's literally what makes
them wake up in the morning
and there's no place i've seen it more
than in the data space
so yeah it's it's uh it's exciting to um
to be a part of that and to have you
part of that and thank you for your
contributions um
thank you for all your support mm-hmm
yeah i'm happy to
um so i'm i'm hoping folks will will
check out the privacy dynamics tool
um that's privacy dynamics dot io
where can they get a hold of you if they
have additional questions or want to get
in touch with you yeah absolutely um and
and anything any questions you have
happy to chat anytime uh
product questions founder questions
getting started questions um
you know one thing pete and i talk about
all the time is this is not some big
bang um
had this brilliant idea and i was born
to be a founder like it's literally a
process that you go through to start a
business so i always love talking about
that stuff too but if you want to get a
hold of me uh
email graham privacy dynamics dot io is
a good spot or uh twitter uh just at
graham thompson
um and
yeah or linkedin whatever whatever you
prefer modern it's great on all of them
so well thanks for your contributions to
the community and i'm sure folks will be
reaching out
absolutely thanks pete a lot of fun
um thanks everyone for tuning in uh
we'll be taking a short break over the
christmas holidays um the year-end
holidays so
you'll see us back in january
um don't forget that data council austin
is our first
irl event post pandemic coming up
january 27th and 28th
of 2022 in austin texas
you can get more information at
datacouncil.ai and get your your
earlybird tickets there
graham will be there
amongst many other amazing uh dozens of
founders
open source leaders data experts
speakers it's going to be an amazing
time so we're hoping that you'll join us
there
so
until then
thanks for tuning in and we'll see